Speaker 1: Another element of propaganda
that we're hearing from the anti-choice
right in the wake of this leaked decision
from the Supreme Court that is believed will
overturn Roe v Wade and Planned Parenthood
v Casey. Essentially eliminating the general
understood federal right to an abortion in
most cases for women. One of the things we're
hearing from the right is that this isn't
going to go any further. It shouldn't be
interpreted that this change to precedent
ending abortion rights as a federal issue
should connect to absolutely any other issue. Now,
I don't believe that for a second. And in fact,
yesterday I tweeted, quote, Some of the people
against abortion are also against gay marriage.
They're against gay adoption. They're against
interracial marriage. They're against divorce.
Some are in favor of it being legal to fire people
for their sexual orientation or gender identity,
which is already legal in many states. This
won't stop here for sure. There are more
people coming around to this perspective.
There's a very good article in Esquire
written by Charlie Pierce called They're Coming
for Griswold and Obergefell and Lawrence and
Loving. And these are decisions that relate to
gay marriage and interracial marriage and other
things. And he says, don't for a second believe
what Alito put in that. Or rather, this is from
I'm sorry, this this is from Antonin Scalia. We
emphasize our decision concerns the constitutional
right to abort all the who wrote this.
You want to see this as a reassurance.
This is from Alito. We emphasize our decision
concerns the constitutional right to abortion and
no other right. Nothing in this opinion should be
understood to cast doubt on precedents that do not
concern abortion. And Charlie Pierce writes God
above. What a crock. They're coming for Griswald
and for Obergefell and for Laurence and for
loving, for all I know. There is no reason to
believe that they're not coming for those things.
And why do I say that? Well, I mean, just look.
Just just look at this. These are justices, all
of them. Alito, Barrett, Gorsuch, Kavanaugh.
We looked at their confirmation hearings
yesterday, and when they were asked about
Roe v Wade, they said, listen, they do their
standard thing. I can't prejudge. I might be
in a situation where I have to bring in all that
stuff. But but I respect precedent. And yet here
they are all voting to overturn precedent. We
can't trust them as far as we can throw them. And
we're already starting to see an inkling of this
among the right. One such example is this guy,
Charlie Kirk, who said, if we can get Roe v Wade
overturned, anything is possible. You don't stop
after a major win. You try to get another one.
Speaker 2: Hello, everybody. Welcome back.
E-mails, your thoughts. Freedom at Charlie Kirkham
and so many other thoughts to kind of unpack here.
But I want to kind of get to one in particular,
which is. If we're trying to save the country,
which we are, and we're looking at repealing
Roe versus Wade, it changes the entire game.
There'll be obviously extraordinary blowback
black on this unlike anything I think we've
ever seen. But this takes courage. Simple
courage by the five justices if they do
what they're signaling. And that's something
that's in short supply right now from our leaders.
It's kind of like oil coming above surface.
It's a sign that there's likely more below.
Boys courage in short supply. But I
think there's more than we put. We even
can put our eyes on right now. And if we can get
Roe versus Wade overturned, anything is possible.
I want to tell you guys about Hillsdale College.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So I don't care about Hillsdale
College, but this is not going to be
the end and it could be contraception
as part of Obamacare that they go for. You know,
when we say interracial marriage, I think that
that's pretty far down the line. I don't I don't
think that that's next. But gay marriage is a
reasonable target. Contraception is a reasonable
target. A lot of these things are going to be
targets when you get your big I mean, think back
think back to maybe one of the greatest basketball
teams in history, the Chicago Bulls of the 1990s.
You know, they won those first three championships
and then Jordan retired and then it was like, this
is as far as we go, even though we're the best.
But they didn't end there. They had to come
back and keep going. And they got three
more. And I don't find anything equivalent
morally between people like Charlie Kirk
and the great Jordan and Scottie Pippen era Bulls
of the 1990s. But in all seriousness, you don't
stop after you get a major when you actually
keep going. And that's very, very scary stuff.